[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24
soy herminia fernández comenzamos
hoy les traemos un nuevo episodio de
nuestra serie sobre las fronteras del
mundo nos dirigimos al lago victoria en
áfrica algunas de las islas que se
encuentran en este lago el más grande
del continente africano están divididas
por la frontera entre uganda y kenia
recientemente los dos países que se
disputan los derechos de pesca en esas
generosas aguas establecieron acuerdos
de paz en la frontera es el caso de la
isla milingo que se encuentra bajo una
especie de doble soberanía este
territorio acoge a centenares de
personas de uganda y kenia los ugandeses
aproximadamente un tercio de la
población
conviven allí con los kenianos bajo la
mirada de las fuerzas policiales de
ambas naciones a continuación el
reportaje de bastian renwick con severin
bardón y olivier marceau
[Música]
en las aguas del lago victoria hay una
isla más pequeña que un terreno de
fútbol
bingo tiene piraguas de colores
casas de zinc 400 habitantes
y dos comisarías
en un intento por relacionarse los
policías ugandeses y kenianos se reúnen
para compartir una comida
y nos sentamos juntos comemos juntos y
para todo lo que tiene que ver con el
trabajo intercambiamos informaciones
oficialmente en vikingo le pertenece a
kenia pero en 2004 las fuerzas ugandesas
desembarcaron en la isla y reivindicaron
su posesión desde entonces el destino de
mingo ha afectado la relación entre
ambos países
es un asunto muy delicado
creo que se firmó un memorando de
entendimiento entre los dos estados
para ponerle fin a la violencia contra
sus ciudadanos en 2019 kenny autorizó la
presencia de policías ugandeses en su
territorio ahora 5 vive bajo una especie
de doble en soberanía pero esta armonía
aparente no oculta el malestar de los
policías kenianos
realmente no sabría decirlo estábamos
aquí en esa época de pronto
cooperamos ellos nos ayudan nosotros les
ayudamos no sé nada sobre el pasado
[Música]
y esperanza
todos los días al comienzo de la tarde
woman vaya conduce a un grupo de
pescadores kenianos por las aguas del
lago victoria
como que la libertad
más que este pedazo de tierra situado a
unos 200 kilómetros de sus costas lo que
atrajo a uganda hasta milingo pero los
derechos y el comercio para la pesca del
nilo
la semana pasada no había peces en el
lado keniano
por eso los dos últimos días nos hemos
ido al lado ugandés
de hecho
para los pescadores kenianos el acuerdo
de 2019 fue beneficioso al aceptar la
presencia de los policías ugandeses en
yingo kenia obtuvo el derecho a pescar
en aguas ugandesas los barcos kenianos
que cruzan la frontera lacustre ya no
son detenidos los guardacostas ugandeses
ya no golpean a los tripulantes solo los
que se atreven a ir demasiado lejos
corren algún riesgo
efe
gastan mucha gasolina y se alejan mucho
de la frontera
ahora
a veces se encuentran con fuerzas del
orden que les roban el pescado o les
roban sus cosas tiran el contenido de
sus galeras al agua a eso se enfrentan
en las aguas más profundas
vaya
[Música]
en agosto de 2021 uno de ellos fue
asesinado a tiros
a más de una hora en barco de vikingo
yoga también echa sus redes en las aguas
ugandesas no se queda en esta zona algo
difusa donde se tolera a los pescadores
kenianos
depende a veces se puede lanzar una red
entera y no pescar nada pero mañana
esperamos regresar con una buena pesca
hoy los barcos volvieron con algo de
pescado y mañana será todavía mejor si
dios quiere
esperamos pescar 50 kilos de pescado eso
equivale a unos 150 euros
ambas cámaras el link el oficial
ahora por lo menos pueden tener
esperanzas después de años de conflicto
el status quo entre ambos países permite
que los pescadores de vikingo tengan un
nivel de vida decente
[Música]
nos alegra que los dos países hayan
logrado firmar ese acuerdo y
ahora los ugandeses son nuestros amigos
vienen a visitarnos vienen a kenia y
nosotros si no estuviéramos tan ocupados
pescando también podríamos ir a uganda
para visitarlos y tener buenas
relaciones
tranquilo
pero uganda está lejos y la pesca es la
prioridad
sin embargo en y ginkgo hay muchos
ugandeses
representan alrededor de un tercio de la
población local
[Música]
creis a magirus es la encargada de uno
de los diez bares de la isla
aquí hay pescadores y policías se
relajan después del trabajo todo el
mundo necesita relajarse
ugandeses kenianos recibo a todos los
que quieran venir a mi bar no hay
diferencias no es un lugar ugandés donde
solo puedan entrar los ugandeses
tras el acuerdo de 2019 esta joven
ugandesa viajó 12 horas en barco desde
su país natal para probar suerte de
milingo
un amigo me habló de este lugar me dijo
que era un buen sitio para vivir que si
se trabajaba duro se podía ganar mucho
dinero aquí entonces lo intente vine y
me di cuenta de que me había dicho la
verdad
la isla tiene la reputación de ser un
pequeño eldorado pescadores camareros
comerciantes kenianos ugandeses todos
decidieron venir a mingo en busca de una
vida mejor
creis había oído hablar de las tensiones
que paralizaron la isla unos años atrás
no esperaba descubrir un lugar el que
fuera tan fácil vivir un lugar donde
kenianos ugandeses cohabitan en parte
incluso aunque aquí el vendedor le pide
hablar en kiswahili para recordarle que
está en genial
quiero 20 schillings de tomates y 20
innings decente
compre pescado y después vine aquí a
comprar tomates es fácil hay muchas
tiendas aquí siembra no tiene lo que
estoy buscando voy a otra y encuentro lo
que necesito después puedo preparar la
comida a mis hijos y a más empleadas
es como vivir en tierra field tenemos
acceso a todos
vikingo es la isla más densamente
poblada del mundo aquí se concentra una
sociedad multicultural para grace es
también una tierra de oportunidades con
mucha actividad
yo cocino porque mis empleadas no tienen
tiempo siempre están ocupadas atendiendo
a los clientes
entonces yo preparo comida para ellas
para mis hijos y para mí también
son como hermanas venimos del mismo país
las cuido como si fueran las hermanas
soy amable con ellas
la situación inédita de la isla es una
ventaja para estas mujeres expatriadas
en una tierra que no les resulta
totalmente extranjera trabajar en uganda
no sería tan lucrativo
para un ugandés venir aquí es como ir a
qatar o arabia saudita hay dinero
es decir que si se convierte en 1000
schillings kenianos a moneda ugandesa es
mucho dinero
por eso la mayoría de los ugandeses
quieren trabajar aquí
[Música]
para los kenianos la isla también es
atractiva al estar más cerca de las
zonas de pesca economizar gasolina se
aprovechan los productos ugandeses a
precios bajos
temprano de la mañana los pescadores
regresa al amigo yuma en sus hombres son
los últimos en volver a la isla
hoy el tiempo estuvo bueno pudimos
pescar bien y trajimos entre 20 y 50
kilos de pescado por barco para llamar
juanes al máximo ya mitad
la pesca alcanzó la suma esperada
equivalente a 150 euros
el pescado será despachado a kenia a 50
km de distancia también podría haber
sido enviado a uganda anything o los
aduaneros no se ven por ninguna parte
no podemos decir realmente que estamos
en kenia este lugar está en manos de dos
gobiernos hay policías ugandeses y
kenianos pero nadie nos dice con qué
país tenemos que hablar
pero mientras su actividad prospere más
se preocupa poco por esas cuestiones
políticas
esta es mi casa alquilo cuatro casas a
unos quince euros cada uno
es un buen precio considerando el lugar
donde vivimos y las condiciones que hay
aquí
manent
una chabola de zinc una pequeña mesa dos
camas el lugar es espartano pero yuma
está conforme
a ella
estoy contento de vivir aquí gracias a
eso puedo mandar a mis hijos a la
escuela
gano lo suficiente para mantener a mi
familia
es por este dinero que todos nos hemos
quedado
a pesar de las dificultades que hemos
enfrentado actúan a pensacola el acoso
las violencias ha valido la pena ninguna
megan la quina de donde una patria que
ya no cuenta nada en un van a grace
también le gustaría seguir aprovechando
el dinero de milingo pero hoy tiene una
noticia para su hijo pronto se irán de
la isla para regresar a su pueblo llegó
el momento de ir a la escuela
por donde crees que vamos a regresar por
ahí alguien nos vendrá a recoger vamos a
viajar en un pequeño barco hasta uganda
era de dsiware eléctrica melanocítico
no tenía a nadie con quién dejarlo en
uganda no tengo ni madre ni padre
entonces lo traje aquí conmigo en abril
me iré con él para que pueda asistir al
segundo trimestre estoy un poco triste
de volver allá la vida ahí es más
difícil
aquí tengo todo lo que necesito pero
allá será más duro
será un poco muy duro
shavit
el hígado
grace no tardará en ser reemplazada como
encargada del bar kenianos ugandeses
muchos sueñan con hacer fortuna en yingo
sin importar cual sea la situación de la
isla
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]